why
is childbirth painful and dangerous
walking upright big heads farming
revolution
question mark how will it evolve
considering diets
best regards from finland you would love
it here consider visiting one day
so there's sort of three hypotheses
three possibilities proposed here
walking upright big heads
farming revolution i don't think
agricultural revolution
has anything you know made things
worse with regard to childbirth with the
possible
caveat that if women are less
active certainly not being not being as
fit
makes childbirth more dangerous but the
first two things here
the becoming bipedal um you know that
that move from being quadrupedal to
bipedal
and changing hip shape in order to
become stable
um and not and not and women not having
such wide hips they become
unstable um in combination with
large heads as a result of our big
brains which is a big part of what makes
humans human
that combination is is the thing that is
usually described as
um why childbirth in humans is so much
different and harder and more dangerous
than it is for
everyone else really so i'm surprised to
hear you say you don't think
uh the agricultural revolution or at
least
the um abundance
of food has made things worse because it
seems to think babies are bigger
yeah i think they're going to be less
scrawny but heads aren't fatter
i've run into some fatheads in my day
and i know we say that but it's not
actually what we mean
right and i mean it's possible that
heads um
are also getting bigger but you know the
less scrawny babies and
and and longer babies won't make birth
more difficult it really is head
diameter yeah head diameter which is why
birth has been moved earlier in the
developmental sequence
incidentally actually bob trivers
tweeted yesterday a new result
and i can't remember um maybe while
you're answering something i'll figure
out i can't remember what species it was
in
but that found evidence for
genomic imprinting in which maternally
derived genes
cause gestation to be shorter and
paternally derived genes paternally
imprinted genes
um cause gestation to be longer so you
have so
for for everyone uh rather than us
having this private conversation here
following from david hague's seminal
work in the 1990s
the idea that genes are able to
keep track of what parent they came from
and will have different incentives in
terms
of things like fetal growth depending on
whether or not they came from the mother
who is interested in
the survival and success of her baby but
also in the survival and success of
future babies
or if those genes those alleles came
from the father
who in a non-monogamous species at least
is unlikely to have any future kids with
the with that mother
and so has only an interest in the
maximum survival and success of that
individual and not in the future
reproductive output of
um of the mother so the idea the
prediction then was
that that maternally imprinted genes
maternally derived genes in fetuses
would push towards smaller birth weights
and shorter gestation times and such and
the paternally
imprinted or derived genes would push
towards higher birth rates and
longer gestation times and there's a
piece of empirical research that uh
that finds this that's amazing i did not
catch that tweet nor did i see that
research
yet i will say you just blew right by
that awesome argument in favor of
monogamy one of my
favorite arguments in favor of my
favorite breeding system of all time
i mean it's just saying that because i'm
sitting here um
i'm saying that because i found the
right person i'm sure monogamy is a pain
in the ass if you end up with the wrong
person but
having not ended up with the wrong
person uh i'm all in favor okay so what
did
what what did i blow past well no no you
you said it but it was just like
so fast and the idea so that it's
multifaceted too
the idea is the conflict between
that fraction of the genome of the fetus
that comes from the father
the conflict between that fraction of
the genome and the mother
is much greater if the father is out of
there and therefore has no interest
or little interest in the ongoing
well-being of the mother and
has an interest in his offspring taking
more than its share
whereas if you have a monogamous system
where the next offspring is going to be
his as well
he has a much more concordant interest
and the fetuses have a concordant
interest because
the next offspring is going to be a full
sib rather than a half sib
reduces sibling rivalry so does
yeah it's just a better system it's just
better
[Music]